foreign
foreign
hahaha
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional they are mentally off they
have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but the whole
world will adjust you well we we got it
that's a lot that's a lot we win
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male dog but another date about a dozen
because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of David Pac-Man
he is
[Applause]
David Pac-Man
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not Dave backman oh
that's that that dude is gone that is a
freaking printer right there who thinks
he's smarter than you and she's better
than you and he's gonna beat you he
thinks oh Joe Rogan
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets and shelves
10 times 15 times
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
what on Earth is going on with trumpet
and toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation a big massive dumps Obama
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
the United States thank you very much
elements of bathrooms welcome everybody
it is day two of CPAC and what a day it
has already been we are looking very
strongly at a number of different things
here uh and we are going to continue
doing so this current panel which is
happening live is called who's going to
tell Kamala the panelists are this is
Lynn Patton on your screen right now oh
what are they chanting is it lock
someone up there's a
there's little tickets wow they are both
on top in that equation
oh you people
top of the ticket
so one of the things about CPAC this
year is that I tweeted about this and it
was a pretty strong tweet I would say
the top Applause and standing ovations
are in reaction to homophobic and
transphobic claims and statements that's
the kind of theme this year uh for CPAC
so this is who's going to tell Kamala
Larry O'Connor Rogan oh Handley Kurt
schlichter and Lynn Patton are the four
panelists and
you know I you tell me who's who I I
know that the woman is Lynn Patton but
all the other people I couldn't tell you
who's who but maybe this guy here is
Larry O'Connor I don't know so
interesting things coming up are that
momentarily JD Vance is going to be
speaking now I'm sure that you guys all
know who I'm talking about when I say uh
JD Vance right because you hold on do I
have the thing
here it is we've endorsed JP right JD
Mandel yes JD Vance is who Trump meant
he's speaking and that will be followed
up by Marjorie Trader Green in an event
called I'll take my committees back now
so that's all coming up in the next few
moments now many of you wondering what
the hell is going on here I was going to
stream earlier and I was going to stream
later and it was going to be a longer
stream and a wider stream and a girthier
stream and all these different things
this is the stream of CPAC for today
and then I may stream The Prompt rally
tonight I can't say for sure but I may
do it anyway Donald Trump Donald Trump
yeah so that may be tonight I I think I
would say if we get to 100 members I
will definitely stream tonight and if
not I may or may not we'll we'll just
kind of take it from there let's get
established here and see if we can
establish the stream strongly
um Robert Havens sent a Super Chat hail
Brandon our dark lord and savior of
democracy and the economy absolutely did
you guys see that dark Brandon is now
overseeing a 3.5
unemployment rate
we're basically at full employment in
the United States
God bless
the United States
and more than 500 000 new jobs created
last month it's it's genuinely Bonkers
now honestly I'm not even praising Joe
Biden but a lot of these things just are
much bigger than any one president but
it's getting increasingly hard to argue
that there's an economic disaster and I
know that there's much speculation about
recession or not or these different
things we we have to we have to just
follow what the data is but
it's hard to imagine
some massive recession given full
employment massive consumer demand
declining gas prices what I believe on
Tuesday we will learn is declining uh
inflation overall stock market up nine
percent in July it doesn't seem like a
recession is all I'm saying and I know
there's many economists there's our
audience is filled with PhD economists
who regularly disagree with me in the
chat
um but well that's kind of my take on it
right now
other super chats coming in without
saying what the answer is have you made
up your mind as to whether there is a
stream later no whether there is a
stream later I believe will depend on
whether we get to 100 members in twitch
Prime subscribers now let's just see
what's going on there's Donald Trump
tonight is speaking in a place called
wakrisha Wisconsin and this is what's
going on as you can see the crowd is
so ready for tonight's rally and uh
people taking the shortcut I guess
um this woman taking the long way around
and just a lot happening in Wisconsin
right now but uh there is a rally
tonight let's listen a little bit Grace
adamstein is a little known candidate
who is challenging the current Speaker
of the assembly Robin Voss
and Robin Voss has been a a
disappointment to say the least not just
for those of us that care a lot about
election Integrity so as you can see
it's very exciting outside the Trump
rally in Wisconsin that would
theoretically be tonight and uh I may
stream it I may not we we are going to
see now
pointing in the direction of streaming
or the fact that we are already seeing
membership dumps I want to say thank you
to Terry schweren Joe Rader Joe has been
gifting memberships for a very long time
as well as Jason sickmeyer getting us on
the board at three also over on Twitch
try igamer gen here
Cosmic Huntress
copper bunny
Captain Smiles all grabbing twitch Prime
subscriptions super chat's continuing to
come in two of the memberships I have
gifted have yet to be claimed can they
be given to someone who will claim them
yeah what happens is we will send the
free membership to someone some people
don't claim it and some people think
it's spam they're like nobody would
really be gifting me a membership and
it's like yes people remember people are
are gifting memberships
um so just let us know and then we'll
send them to someone else
Waukesha guys I know it's waukesh I
don't I don't actually think it's
pronounced wakrisha
uh that was a joke I know it's Waukesha
that's just a joke it's just a joke and
for people in the chat asking for free
memberships we have a process you've got
to get in line we will let people in but
they've got to do it legally and in
order
and you go to davidpackman.com free
membership to put your name down saying
you would like a free membership so
again if you're just joining us this is
a panel called
um who's going to tell Kamala featuring
Larry O'Connor Rogan oh Handley Kurt
schlichter and Lynn Patton for people I
have not heard of the next panel is one
called I caramba with David Harris yes
Lee Vega Cassie Garcia and Mercedes
schlapp I can only imagine it's
something about Latino voters uh judging
from the name and the fact that there
are I believe three people considered
Loosely Hispanic on the
um on the panel and then it will go to
JD right JP Mandel and then Marjorie
Trader green and then conspiracy
theorist Jack passaviak
um
and then it gets crazier from there
there's actually a panel where they're
bringing on these two doctors Robert
Malone and Peter McCulloch who are
anti-vaxx doctors it's going to become a
total mess and later Nebraska governor
no oh is it Nebraska or Oklahoma
governor Kevin's tit
is Kevin's tit the Oklahoma or the
Nebraska governor I never remember
anybody
Kevin's tit Oklahoma or Nebraska
Oklahoma okay
Oklahoma governor Kevin's tit yeah
that's later
um and then tomorrow it will be Donald
Trump but tonight Trump is speaking in
uh in Wisconsin okay all right couple
other super chats
having phone banked for campaigns before
and people can be awful at times on the
phone what tips can you provide to get
help get the positive message across in
aiding campaigns ask an expert on phone
banking I've uh I've never done it so I
just I don't want to weigh in on things
I'm not I don't know anything about
and big thank you to Haley from Georgia
who has gifted 10 YouTube memberships
we're gonna count those today that puts
us at 18.
so website memberships at joinpakman.com
twitch subscriptions and YouTube gifts
we're counting all of it we're counting
all of it thanks to Bob Walsh for
signing up at joinpakman.com also Alex
Skinner and Brian Potts have gifted
memberships that puts us at 21 and Well
on our way to another stream tonight
also thanks to slacks and Polo for the
twitch Prime Membership all right let's
listen a little bit I mean after all we
are sort of here for CPAC let's just see
what level of Bonkers is happening but
then I want to go to some of the
highlights and low lights from yesterday
and today oh it's not commless not
anyone else on this list all these
Democrats how about this one for the
Democratic nomination for president in
2024 Liz Cheney
uh for Larry she's a shoe-in to take her
home state of Virginia
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I didn't know Miss Piggy would be
eligible eligible
yeah Liz Cheney is considered a rhino a
rhino
all these segments into little bites
it's like what are they gonna do with
this Yeah medium ABS can bite us
I mean look you know she and Kevin
Costner have one thing in common they're
both fake ranches and neither live in
Wyoming is this a comedy one is this
supposed to be funny I have to leave it
up to you to fill in these blanks um but
uh we have determined one thing these
guys are awesome
Lynn Patton I'm Larry O'Connor thank you
for saving this country
[Music]
all right now with the country saved
these absolute American Heroes can walk
off the stage
um they are running about 20 minutes
behind right now this was supposed to
have ended 20 minutes ago coming up next
is a panel called icaramba with David
Harris yes Lee Vega Cassie Garcia and
Mercedes schlapp that's next that will
be followed by a defiant and principled
speech by JD Vance called the rise of
the hillbilly and then after that we
will hear from Marjorie Trader green I'm
going to be streaming for a couple hours
then I've got a few things to do and
um later okay yeah so this is the I
guess this the idea here is this is the
Latino panel
um I can only imagine how inspirational
this is going to be let's actually
listen to a little bit of this I'm sort
of curious
so everybody knows I am Latin American
I'm an immigrant from Argentina English
is my second language just in case
anybody finds any of the commentary I
might have about this seemingly
inappropriate in some way let's play
identity politics and I'll just remind
you that I am Argentinian no we were the
the title of this panel is
but it's because the original title was
breakfast tacos but Jill Biden took that
title from us
wow whoever is writing for this thing
they should be writing for The Daily
Show yeah so you're running for congress
in the great state of Texas which
district 28 okay 28. so if you're in
District 28 this is the person you're
gonna vote for okay and you know you've
seen this transition happening right now
you're running against Henry Cuellar the
district has fundamentally changed dear
God let's hope Henry wins I
I got this to Congress in June it's the
same Red Wave it's going to send me to
Congressman that Red Wave is dead
Democrats are now leading Red Wave is
going to say Nancy Pelosi packing come
this November so we are excited we are
here yes yeah and your goal is and I was
reading about um you know what you're
pushing for it's about protecting The
Unborn it is about protecting our
constitution what do you think is a big
message that you're going to drive of
come November yeah so I am so excited to
be running for congress I'm running to
defend faith family and freedom in South
Texas district 28 we are conservative
and the Democrat Party has left the
Hispanic Community we do not support
open borders we support a strong and
secure border and this Administration
who says we have a closed border we have
news for you come this November we are
going to flip district 28 red
yes let's hope not
this is what the New York Times calls
the far right Latina is she a far right
Latina well I don't know she hasn't said
much yet but the fact that she's
obsessed with abortion sounds like it is
latinx he him I don't know I gotta talk
to him about this we're very concerned
David you are such a powerhouse on
social media you are the one who speaks
the truth and you're saying to this
especially to the black community come
home come to the conservative movement
what are your selling points what are
you telling them what's the message well
when it comes to the Democratic base of
today so many people are waking up
because the Democrats just continue to
push crazy am I right they just continue
to push right the craziest initiatives
in uh Pennsylvania they're literally
saying that three-year-olds can
transition
three-year-olds are you kidding me is
that even true I haven't heard that
that's happening if you can believe that
did they say that like a boy can wear
high heels if he wants I mean what does
it mean what are they even talking about
any of us that have grand baby have
babies or have grandkids to think about
what the Democrats are currently doing
right now what they're pushing on our
children they are literally trying to
steal the innocence of our kids yes
they're trying literally or
metaphorically parent anywhere that if
they found out that a teacher was
talking
heterosexual activity of any kind to a
three four five six year old that that
parent wouldn't be going to the police
and that teacher would be arrested now
the Democrats are pushing all of this on
our children and they're just standing
back parents are are fed up in the
Democrat base the the parents that have
common sense and especially believe in
love Jesus I think America needs Jesus
right now amen America needs Jesus right
now more than ever and you're not
hearing that from Democrats I had an
amazing no uh because Democrats respect
the separation of church and state it's
something that I said you know you don't
hear that in in Democrat uh because it's
unconstitutional said I'm going to
listen to Holy Spirit
you know he's right Democrats aren't
saying we're going to listen to the Holy
Spirit to determine what policies we do
the Bible
they don't profess in that they profess
in something else that is that is no
identity it's gender confusion it's
gender dysphoria and it's an all-out
assault and attack on the identity of
our children instead of telling telling
them that their identity comes from God
uh and it's waking people up all across
the Democratic base Independence and
it's making Republicans even more more
fierce in their uh in their
determination and you know just to
follow up on that story when I said the
Holy Spirit the first thing David did he
put his hand over my shoulder and prayed
over me right this beautiful prayer what
a good guy for each other yes we got to
pray for each other yes you have to pray
for our families we have to pray for our
country we have to pray for our children
don't give up on your children if you
think your children are turning away
bring them back to the light let them
know they are loved and that's what we
have to do this is really occult I mean
it is crazy how much this is a cult
another Republican Congressional
candidate in a very competitive seat in
Virginia which I believe we are going to
win and as well you decided to run you
jumped into this race what made you say
I'm going to take this chance I'm a
proud conservative Latina well I'll say
it until my very last breath we live in
the greatest country in the history of
the world Amen
yes we do yes
how many veterans do we have in this
room tonight can you raise your hand can
we hear it for our veterans thank you
for your service you are our national
treasure this is very pandery
I've never been one to back away from a
fight I am a mother of two beautiful
kids and I've always said this I do not
co-parent with the government okay those
babies are a blessing to my husband and
I and we're responsible for their
upbringing they're educating and what
we've seen as David stated has been a
full-blown assault on our children and
as a mom you better believe that I'm not
going to sit on the sidelines and just
watch this so they're really playing up
the they're attacking our kids stuff
here and I decided to run at the local
level in 2019 we won not by shying away
from our conservative values but by
proudly and boldly highlighting them and
talking about them and let me tell you
this is the year that we take back the
house fire Nancy Pelosi and set the
stage for the Great American comeback of
2024. yeah
thank you
I love it okay so
if you're not inspired already I don't
know what to tell you you're in the room
I know that it is it is hard if this is
not inspirational to you then what would
do it of the Republican Party they're
the voices all of them that we need to
continue this fight you're married to a
border patrol agent you've seen the
devastation at the border I know you
talked about it a little bit earlier but
give us a sense of the battle that
you're by the way how it's like it's so
histrionic the devastation at the border
like what are they even talking about I
was down not that long ago I spent some
time in uh in Arizona and I was all
along the Arizona border with Mexico and
the California border I didn't see any
Devastation whatsoever like it it seemed
fine everything was fine I was home
these conversations that you're having
what they're all seeing at the border
thank you so we have a nickname for
Kamala it's que Mala because uh we don't
know where she's at right they have a
nickname for the already mispronounced
Kamala which they say Kamala
um these people are sick all right we're
going to mute this a little bit because
it's
you know a little bit nauseating coming
up next is JP Mandel and then after that
Marjorie Trader green but I think this
kind of gives you a sense of the level
on on which they're operating I want to
hear from some of you guys here
um David my guns were taken away now I'm
eating Elwood's organic dog meat the
labrador Stakes are fantastic yeah what
the reference there is that Lauren
Lauren bobert said that if you take away
assault weapons people will start eating
dogs why I don't know
I genuinely have no idea why people
would eat dogs if they didn't have an
AR-15 I just don't understand the
connection but that's what Lauren bobert
said all right let's um let's catch up
on a couple other things first of all
CPAC day two I'll be here for a few
hours if we get to a hundred new members
twitch subscribers and gifted YouTube
memberships I will stream the Trump
rally tonight the Trump rally tonight
people can already go if you're in
Waukesha Wisconsin as you can see look
at the excitement feel the excitement of
course Donald Trump if he were indeed to
speak tonight would I'm sure make a
whole bunch of different very clear and
important declarations and statements
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy that could yeah fresh
vegetables Americans of all walks of
life rose up Mexico
JP right JD Mandel no more Dropbox
60 minutes
yeah so that's some of what you could
expect to hear tonight certainly and uh
I I may be streaming that
so that's going on I want to say thank
you to people supporting the stream via
twitch Zeno The Stranger agent Trav and
ASF klops putting us at 25. look at that
we are filling her up and then also want
to say thank you to
risto
turakowski who just I hope I'm not
butchering that who just signed up on my
website thank you also to Tom wiemann
for gifting a subscription Lisa Rader
has sent a gift Rebecca Hayes just
gifted a membership Julie zaring thank
you to
uh hold on a second here Jason sickmeyer
and Luke trefry putting us at 32.
all much much appreciated
other super chats coming in David do you
think most argentinians like us in the
U.S vote democrat or republican oh
Democrat no this is not a it's not a
question of opinion Solange it's that uh
basically
um Latin Americans Latinos Hispanic
whatever word you want to use
a very left-wing group with the
exception of Cuban Americans and to some
degree Venezuelan Americans but outside
of those they tend to be more right-wing
sort of reactions to they see themselves
as by supporting Republicans opposing
the the Castro and Chavez Maduro regimes
you be the judge as to whether that
makes sense but outside of Cuban
Americans and Venezuelan Americans Latin
Americans from South America Chile
Argentina Bolivia Peru you know et
cetera a very very left wing rely almost
as less left-wing as Jewish Americans
um um three of the most uh liberal
constituencies are Jewish Americans
black Americans and then to a slightly
lesser degree Hispanic Americans uh
let's see what else we have going on
here oh let's yeah let's look at a
couple of clips from earlier because it
has been wild at CPAC absolutely wild uh
oh hold on this is good too here's uh
some kind of interview from the Trump
rally that's going on tonight it doesn't
where are you from
uh Wisconsin do you love president Trump
right yes why don't you show everybody
your cute little doll there a little
trumpy bear there that's really cute and
uh we've got uh hey you got the man
himself out here how you doing
tremendous how are you
oh
I don't know that I can do the rally
tonight to be totally Frank guys
that is really bumming me out
man
let's just move on without comment okay
uh Peter Ducey asked why the president
is bragging about gas prices last one
why is the president bragging today
about gas prices because it's gone down
oh man that's pretty good all right
here's a woman at the Trump rally today
showing off her custom Trump outfit guys
take a look at this Wisconsin's very own
Trump gown Wisconsin I like that
Wisconsin this made a woman from Berlin
Wisconsin made this I brought all the
fabric for it and had it made and it
represents God and Country it represents
president Trump yeah when I see that
dress I think about Jesus that's
definitely definitely what I'm thinking
about
uh let's see what else we've got here
um I guess this is at CPAC Sarah Palin
was asked what are her priorities if she
gets elected to congress it went to its
ultimate end and then hold people
accountable not only
and give up on the other corrupt acts
that put our country in the position
that we're in like the 30 000 emails
that were erased and oh that was okay
Hillary did that Benghazi oh my gosh all
these things were oh yeah we're gonna
investigate Congress should be having
this these badass huge rallies on the
steps of the Capitol and it should be
congressmen they have the platform they
should be having these press conferences
they should even have be having fireside
chat chats they should do whatever they
can to get them Fireside charts wow that
would be crazy out there with the
message to the public to let them know
what's going on right
they don't seize the opportunity she
seems to have a very strange appearance
anyway so Hillary's emails I guess are
like a really big thing for Sarah Palin
right now that's uh that's that's
interesting Rick Scott delivered a
Bonkers speech at CPAC he seemed to be
making very little sense now the ideas
from these people never make sense but
what I mean here is that
it like the words didn't even make sense
everyone will obey and no one will be
allowed to complain
if you do speak up boom you're going to
be canceled
your views if you don't conform with big
Tech
fauci or Neil Young
gonna be taking off Spotify YouTube
Facebook and Twitter if you don't go
along with fauci's views you get taken
off of sparify man that I don't want
that to happen to me
the militant left America are the modern
day version of book burners right
look at how pleased he looks did you see
that pause that was an Applause line but
all you heard was like
and then he paused and then the Applause
came what a pathetic clown
the militant left America are the modern
day version of book burners
[Applause]
this is insane
the modern day version of book burners
canceling silence and banning from the
Internet is book burning right these are
the most narrow-minded intolerant people
our country has ever seen
these Applause lines are really not
working too well
they're completely ignorant of both
world history and American history
socialism leads to two things I didn't
know that Rick Scott struggled to speak
so much that his diction was so terrible
I just I guess I've never heard them
speak that much poverty and depression
foreign
's not a new idea
it's one of the dumbest oldest most
discreet ideas of the 20th century that
resulted in the deaths of 100 million
people
if he's Democrats he's almost pleased by
that we have no idea how the real world
works or acting like they just invented
socialism right the modern wacky left
Democrat has never read George Orwell
hey that I don't think that's true
don't know they're making his
predictions come true
let's be clear what the militant left is
now proposing is not simply wrong it is
evil
man what an electric speaker huh just
unbelievable energy bringing bringing it
to the table
let's see what else we have this is from
The Alex Jones trial we'll skip that for
now
uh let's see what other Clips we have
from CPAC we're standing by for JP
Mandel
uh but I did want to see a few other
things
here is
um let's see Trump rally musical choices
are undefeated let's see what they're
playing
[Applause]
Highway to Hell yeah that's that's
pretty basically on on the nose I would
say
um let's see what else we've got here
oh Ted Cruz is doing his whole pronoun
game
well my name is Ted Cruz and my pronouns
are kiss my ass
whoa he really showed them guys wow that
is powerful absolutely powerful powerful
stuff there
uh uh man what what energy is being
brought to these events it's really
stunning stuff all right we're waiting
for JD Vance followed by Marjorie Trader
green at day two of CPAC this is stream
one for today there may be a second
stream if we get to a hundred website
members twitch subscribers and gifted
YouTube memberships Danny has just
gifted two more via YouTube that puts us
at 34. thanks to uh blueberry babe
gifting three
Jam lock Sterling Lana
Captain smiles and Andy Yamashiro that
puts a set 40
and then thanks to the gifted
subscriptions from Tommy horse will on
my website and John stapler
we are now at 42 which is okay so let me
think about this how what's
percentage-wise where are we on the path
to 142 divided by a hundred four into 10
is 0.4 nothing to carry 2 into 0 is 0.2
I guess that's what like 43 of the way
there
42 out of 100
I think that's 43 percent or something
I know I'm doing it too fast I apologize
I got to slow it down
um David have you read the Paradox of
democracy I have not what are you
reading right now I just finished one of
Richard Preston's books uh the one about
the 2014 Ebola outbreak in West Africa
I'm now reading
um McIntyre is the last name I forget
the author's first name I'm reading the
um the story of uh of uh
American CIA turned KGB spy Kim philby
by McIntyre which is pretty good and
then for fiction I'm reading Blake
Crouch's new book upgrade which is very
entertaining we need to find David 58
more members in twitch give him a break
I know hold on I have that here where is
it
looking for immigrants not to vote if
Democrats provide no relief would you
please explain why this is a horrible
idea I have not heard about it I need to
figure it out before I can uh tell you
more about it so we are moments away
from JD Vance who is going to speak I
want to say thank you to patheticus
Avalanche of spinach fun dude
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
today's coupon code on the website is
indict why do we care about the website
we care about the website because
whenever you support us on other
platforms which I love
everybody's taking slices slices slices
they're slicing this thing up so thin
it's going to be see-through twitch
takes a slice YouTube takes a slice
patreon takes a slice all these people
are taking slices when you sign up at
joinpakman.com we pay two percent for
the credit debit card fee 98 cents of
every dollar goes into the coffers of
the David packman show that's why that's
why the website is the way to go and you
can use the coupon code indict to save a
bunch of money you can also use the
coupon code Obama Obama to save even
more money I don't like to make a big
deal out of it but it is available uh to
certain people really to everybody we
make it available to everybody all right
and again if we get to a hundred I will
do another stream tonight from wakrisha
Wisconsin here's what's going on there
as you can see an extremely electric
atmosphere in Wisconsin awaiting Donald
Trump's arrival tonight as we stand by
for JD Vance David sir loved the show do
you have a presence on Truth Central
please advise it's truth social also
known of course as truth Central truth
essential right and I am on there Orwell
was a socialist who fought under the
partido obrero the unification marxista
on the Republican side of the Spanish
Civil War don't give revisionists even
an inch Homage to Catalonia great book
thank you Alvaro beautiful message not
sure if you're a fan of Malcolm Nance
but I recommend watching this interview
with the Commonwealth Club scary but he
makes it palatable I will check that out
crazy I got an advanced copy of upgrade
I'm a Blake Crouch Stan so happy so many
people like him too yeah Emily um I've
interviewed Blake Crouch he's been on
the show you know I never like got into
what would be called horror books or as
Bernie Sanders would call them Hara
uh but I actually and that wasn't bad I
actually um have read a bunch of Blake
Crouch's stuff just because I like him
he's been on the show I think I I
believe he's he's been on the show
unless I imagine that it was years ago
and so I've read a bunch of his stuff
all right here he is guys this is JD
Vance the guy Trump I guess thought he
endorsed but like it wasn't completely
clear we've endorsed JP right JD Mandel
we support Vance's opponent Tim Ryan
let's listen to the trash this is
awesome I've even got some of my family
here so it's gonna get especially Rowdy
here
um so I I wanted to introduce myself to
those of you watching uh on TV and also
those of you in the audience who don't
know who I am I am JD Vance I'm a
business guy but I am now the Republican
Senate nominee in the state of Ohio and
ladies and gentlemen we're going to take
that Senate
um I I grew up in Southwestern Ohio I
was raised by my mama and Papaw who came
from Southeastern Kentucky coal country
and so let me just give some context
this story about mama and papa JD Vance
wrote a book called hillbilly elegy
about his upbringing and as a kind of
conservative guy and when I read the
book prior to him running I was like you
know this guy seems like a reasonable
conservative he used to be anti-trump I
was like if I don't agree with him but
he at least seems someone you can talk
to he then went full trumpian off the
charts vile unhinged and it made me want
to burn the book I didn't because I
don't actually burn books but it made me
want to burn the book why are they in
the why are they in the in the wardrobe
why are they in the uh in the silverware
drawer and we realized that mammal who
couldn't get around that well towards
the end of her life she wanted to make
sure that no matter where she was at any
moment she was within Arm's Reach of a
gun and she could bust a cap if she
needed to
ah
by the way if I recall from the book
mama was a Kennedy Democrat uh but she
was she was she was not just a lover of
the Second Amendment she was an
incredible woman she was a
disciplinarian she was tough she could
she could be firm uh she could be firm
with the people she loved and also the
people she didn't know I remember when I
got came home from from school one day
and I said Mama this is right after we
invaded Iraq in April of 2003. and I
said Mama I would like to enlist in the
U.S Marine Corps and she said no you're
not
I said well why and she said well
because I'm not letting anybody go to
the Marine Corps given what's going on
she loved the Marines she loved the
individual Marines but she was scared
like a lot of young parents and
grandparents are for their kids and so
when I brought the recruiter over to our
house to try to persuade her uh that she
should let me enlist in the United
States Marine Corps she told the
recruiter if you step one foot on my
porch I'll blow it off
and so they had a conversation about the
U.S Marine Corps while she stood up on
her porch and he stood in the yard and
that was how he eventually persuaded my
memo that I could join the Marine Corps
and
and
the reason I'm running for Senate the
reason that I love this country is
because the country was so good to me
the people who were here
um you know supporting me the people who
are always there for me everybody from
you know Public School teachers who took
an interest in me to the Marine Corps
drill instructors Who provided needed
discipline this country ladies and
gentlemen is a great place and it was an
especially great place to a kid like me
and for that reason I believe it's time
to step up it's time to fight for it and
ladies and gentlemen it is time to save
this country and do it in the right way
yes
which in this particular race race you
do by voting for his opponent Tim Ryan
who's been a guest on this show think
about where
age of 38 where else could a kid who
grew up you know in a non-traditional
family where things weren't always easy
have the opportunity and the ability to
start a business and to be a husband a
good father to raise three children in a
city that we love this country ladies
and gentlemen don't ever let them tell
you that it's not worth fighting for
don't ever let them tell you that it's
not worth saving because a country that
can provide those dreams and those
rights is anyone saying the country's
not worth saving I haven't heard anybody
say that we need to save and ladies and
gentlemen at this conference we are
dedicated to doing just that
uh-huh
now I was endorsed in my race by
President Trump and I expect that
hopefully he'll come back to the state
of Ohio and campaign with us a little
bit but there was something that
President Trump said something that had
never gotten as much attention as I
thought it should because you hear a lot
about this word dreamers about people
who are in this country some of them in
this country illegally and about the
dreams that they have and he said that
you know what we never talk enough about
is that American citizens have dreams
too
and I think about do people pay to go to
CPAC or do they get paid to go to CPAC
when so many of our citizens ladies and
gentlemen thanks to the policies of the
Democrats and the bite Administration
thanks to the woke corporations Who
Silence Americans and ship American jobs
overseas there are a lot of American
citizens that are having their dreams
Challenge and ladies and gentlemen it is
time that we here in this room fought
for them and that's exactly what we are
going to do
that we
now when you grow up in a family doesn't
have a lot of money there are little
things that you notice little things
that you might not notice and so I want
to just tell you something very briefly
I was talking to somebody uh who is
involved in the grocery business and he
told me that one of the things that
they're seeing right now is that people
aren't buying hamburger and hot dog buns
as much they're buying a lot of white
bread and I remember in my mammal's
house when money got especially tight
that was one of the first things that
you cut out is you replaced hamburger
and hot dog buns with white bread so our
hamburger and hot dog buns white bread
country are buying white bread it's
because the Joe Biden economy has made
it hard for families to have hot dogs
with hot dog buns and that is an
unacceptable thing ladies and gentlemen
our people he will bring back hot dogs
and one of those dreams is that they
should be able to have a family cookout
with hamburger buns and they should be
able to fill up their gas tank with a
reasonable price gasoline those are the
dreams gasp has declined 50 days in a
row
[Music]
but don't even get him started on
sausages
you dream of being able to send their
children to school where they're taught
that American history is something to be
proud of and not something to be ashamed
of our people they dream of being able
to send their kids to trade schools to
jobs to universities to apply for those
things without explicit racial
discrimination which is something that I
guarantee you we all know is happening
in this country right at this very
minute they dream of being able to go
into the drugstore and buy
pharmaceutical ingredients antibiotics
by the way he's talking about white
people being discriminated against to be
clear I know some of you might have
heard that and thought oh wow he cares
about racism he's talking about white
people being discriminated against
they dream of being able to send their
kids to the Marine Corps and to the
other military branches where they're
not kicked out for refusing to take a
vaccine for a disease that is not a
danger to those young kids right the
other 14 vaccines you need in the
military those are fine they only have a
problem with this one
they dream of a country where the
Attorney General puts the people in jail
who burn down American cities not the
people who are protesting peacefully at
their kids school
protesting peacefully at my kid's school
completely normal behavior for parents
to show up at their children's school to
protest and Badger administrators people
who just want a good life in the country
that their grandparents and
great-grandparents built the people who
want their children to have a better
life than they did they are winnable
they are winnable in 22 more than any
other time I'm JD Vance you can go to my
website I'm at jdvance.com and I want
you to support me I want you to make
phone calls for me I want you to go out
there if you're in Ohio and knock on
doors for me because the dream this guy
has to be defeated going to become a
reality when you have a president like
the one that we have right now and a
week fake
Congressman named Tim Ryan in Ohio who
is actually fighting against the very
working people that he's Tim Ryan's
actually a pretty good congressman and a
smart guy he's been on the show 42 to
take this country back to fight for this
country's values and we are not going to
do it unless we get engaged unless we
get energized unless we record we will
also end Kaiser rolls and bialys for
hamburgers media to the propagandists to
the Joe Biden Administration we are
going to send a message that the
American people we have dreams to and
it's time to fight for him thank you and
God bless you
[Applause]
so there is JD Mandel endorsed by Trump
unbeknownst to everybody even
unbeknownst to Trump seemingly and next
we will be hearing from Marjorie Trader
green that is coming up soon I want to
thank Milo Wilde samanthan
boshimonos and Elias His Highness for
the twitch Prime subscriptions putting
us at 49 Kevin Taylor has just gifted
five YouTube subscriptions putting us at
54 and significant membership dumps
happening on the website I want to say
thank you to Mara loughridge who's a new
member thank you Mara I want to say
thank you to Neil Jaworski and then
gifted memberships from Jami bouj Amy
rugela Jamila bouj with two gifted
memberships and then Zeno The Stranger
that's five more seven total 54 plus
seven seven and four is eleven one carry
the one that's 61. we are now 61 percent
of the way to a second stream today I
will stream the Trump rally tonight
checking in in Wisconsin
uh pillow in Wisconsin oh Fox no news
max shame on them I mean is it but look
at what's happened since then we've
froze up look at all
look at ours yes you know I think
Lindell who spoke earlier today at CPAC
he must have flown there on a machine
right we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines so there is pillow
in Wisconsin for tonight uh JD Vance
strongly standing up against potato
bread as well as brioche for burgers
this will not stand
we will have we rose up against brioche
absolutely thanks to Jen here for
gifting a subscription on Twitch as well
BW Rock Says CPAC 2022 agenda to bring
white bread and hot dog bun prices down
says multi-millionaire hillbilly fans
exactly right
exactly right that's absolutely the
Absurd theme of this completely pathetic
event so next is uh an event called I'll
take my committees back now it will
involve someone named Sarah Carter and
radical repugnant congresswoman Marjorie
Trader green that is coming up next
thank you to Travis falls for the
website subscription 63. folks let's not
miss out on the second stream tonight
we are at 63 out of 100 with Marjorie
Trader about to come out and I believe
we can do it it is my belief that the
American people and all of the people in
our audience can do it here is Marjorie
Taylor green with someone named Sarah
Carter this is going to be as weaponized
as any of us can imagine
[Music]
[Applause]
Marjorie Taylor green is like a cartoon
character
[Music]
I I told uh congresswoman green I said
everyone here is waiting to see you they
want they want to hear you yeah
thank you well I was just saying you
know Sarah and I we need a whole hour
out here with you guys oh God please now
please we would love to do it they are
going to keep us on a timer so I'm going
to start off with the first question and
I'm gonna and I told you I'm going to
give you an opportunity to respond to
these allegations
um and lies we saw memes and lies I
showed you one of them trying to compare
your statements to Adolf Hitler
well there we go the lacquer from the
crowd is exactly right well you know
what Sarah I take that very seriously
um ever since I become a member of
Congress I've been the most attacked
member of Congress in the United States
history and I'm appalled by it and so is
my family and so are my friends and so
are my district being kicked off
committees and lied about constantly in
the media is disgusting what a victim
all of us are fed up with it but when I
said that I'm a Christian nationalist I
have nothing to be ashamed of because
that's what most Americans are you kind
of do your face
you kind of do have something to be
ashamed of
we're proud of our faith and we love
principles you know is there anything
wrong with loving God and loving others
no the facts are that America is less
religious over time it is perpetually
less and less and less religious
and Americans first then we really will
win and the Democrats will not destroy
our country so I don't back down from
those comments but I've denounced the
line media for what they've said enough
of it and
yeah you've seen that over and over
again this is an issue that has been
first and foremost I think ever since
2016. specifically we saw the nation you
know um in turmoil political turmoil the
weaponization well I guess that this
Sarah Carter is a current Fox News
anchor from what I'm seeing online
Republicans who supported him talk a
little bit about that and how that not
only affects the members of Congress and
how you're going to handle that in the
future but affects the American people
well I think it affects all of us and
what I've seen in Washington ever since
I've gotten there is fear because of
these lies in the media and look at what
we've all dealt with why is it that the
mainstream media and why is it that the
trolls all over social media and you
know the ones that run the big Tech
platforms why did they get to lie about
President Trump his administration
Republicans like me why does CNN get to
sell the Russian collusion lie over and
over and over again and now sell Liz
Cheney's lie of January 6 over and over
and over why do they get call me
horrific names and call you horrific
names kick all of you off of social
media and silence your voices what names
has CNN called Marjorie Taylor green
then
anybody like Alex Jones who who did say
some things what
but yet he is being politically
persecuted right now and being forced to
pay out millions and millions defending
Alex Jones no one no one agrees with
what he said but what we're tired of is
the political persecution I'd like to
know when the Democrats and the Liars in
the media and the people that canceled
all of you and me on big Tech when are
they going to pay all of us millions of
dollars right
well I tell you what Sarah hears this
when Republicans take back the house I'm
going to be one member of Congress
that's there to hold everyone
accountable and I think that's the most
important thing I can do
let's let's talk about that when
Republicans take back the house if that
happens this November what are you going
to be your main priorities and oh you're
I mean they're talking about you for
oversight right now get ready for this
let's let's talk a little bit about that
yeah do you guys want to see me on the
oversight committee
Dear God
yeah there'll be some fire coming out of
that that committee uh Sarah you have
reported on
credible abuses uh just outright
breaking laws horrible things that we've
seen from our politicians and those are
the type of things I'd like to go after
here I'll just give you guys a few what
do you guys think about Anthony fauci
and Dr Rachel Levine
do Trends practices Frankenstein science
that led to the creation of covid-19 I
think he should be fired what do you
guys think oh so she's going with
fauci-made covet oh very good point
because and just to clarify for everyone
Senator Rand Paul Senator Rand Paul has
been very open about this as well
there's been evidence that the Wuhan
Laboratories knew that when the virus
was released it would go across the
globe now there's evidence that NIH
funded
funded Wuhan Laboratories I love how
she's acting like this is new when it
when the truth is like three weeks ago
we got a report that's like yeah it was
of animal origin in a Wuhan in a Wuhan
wet Market yes absolutely not only do we
need to get to the truth we need to hold
them accountable if they listen if they
can have a fake January 6 committee that
is persecuting president Trump's
Administration and staff innocent people
and if they have a Judicial System a
Department of Justice and an FBI that
has led to the persecution of American
citizens that did go in the capital on
January 6 but now they're being held in
jail still to this day
that they need to be held accountable we
can't be the Republican party that just
talks the talk on the campaign Trail
anymore Sarah we have to be the
Republican party that delivers
all right
what
as far as the Republican Party
do you feel that there are divisions
within the Republican party as well that
you're standing up to maybe and we've
heard this before an establishment will
we see more unification of that
Republican Party come November or 2024
well I will tell you this and I've
always been open and honest about it
there is a civil war in the GOP but but
I'll tell you what Sarah I lean into it
because I know that iron sharpens iron
there's one way to the craziest people
in the Republican Party are going to win
the war is what she's telling us out in
inside in our meetings and in our
offices and that's what we've been doing
we've been doing it for months but
here's what I really want to see from
our Republican conference like I said
our voters and I and I've been saying
this our voters and our donors and
everyone that supports the Republican
party they aren't going to support us if
we do not stop what's happening to
America we're a country with over 30
trillion dollars in debt we're a country
that has wide open borders we're a
country that is that is that is in in a
recession no matter how they Define it
we does anybody know in what way the
borders are quote wide open or when
absolutely they cannot each of us are
made in the image of God In His Image
male and female In His Image and if
we're in the Republican party that is
that is willing to not only close our
borders to the Daily border Invasion if
we're at the Republican party that isn't
capable of stopping the crime and
putting criminals in jail if we're in
the Republican party that is that isn't
capable of Defending children and
protecting them from genital mutilation
puberty blockers and just outright
perverse teachings in in our
taxpayer-funded schools then what kind
of party are we and we will not deserve
nor nor will we get man that's quite a
word salad there so I will be urging my
colleagues look we've got to fight
harder than ever before because the
Democrats have showed us who they are
Sarah and you've seen them you have
reported on it over and over oh and we
have to stop them you brought up a great
Point yeah she she brought up a very
good point here
see who someone is it's important that
certain positions in government carry
certain qualities now I'm not going to
put you completely on the spot here as
for house speaker
but what are
right oh
I mean you can go there if you want but
what are the qualities that you look for
in a Speaker of the House what I'm
looking for is fearless leadership
I'm looking for a speaker I'm looking
for a speaker that's not going to be
pushed around by the lobbyists and the
corporate packs because I don't take
their money
and I'm looking for a speaker
I'm looking for a speaker that is going
to think about those small business
owners the same way they think about the
corporate owners and the same way they
think about the janitors the truck
drivers and the factory workers I want a
speaker that's going to put America
First all of your money first our
borders and our children's future above
everything that's the future Speaker of
the House
so who's that
and my my last question because we had
such a short amount of time and I would
have asked her about everything from
Hunter Biden to Afghanistan right and I
would have said oh my God they've missed
Hunter Biden as a topic what is your
advice to
the American people about these midterms
and how important it is for each and
every one of us to be involved in the
political process do you have any advice
for that absolutely this is we are a
government for the people and by the
people and ladies and gentlemen if you
sit home and you sit it out then you're
going to keep having the government that
you have and that's what's happened for
decades now we haven't held them
accountable and I take as much blame as
anyone what you have to do is you have
to show up and vote even if you don't
trust your elections because if we sit
down on the sideline it's like watching
a battle rage in front of us your vote
will be stolen by democrats but you
should still vote you have to volunteer
and work the polls you have to make sure
that they count the ballots correctly
and I think in Arizona we just saw some
crazy Shenanigans but some great people
won
but we have to we have to care if we
want the country that we know that we
know we have and we know we love and we
know we're going to continue to fight
for for our kids in the future we have
to show up and that's how we're going to
hold them accountable and that is how
we're going to help and make this
country great again because I know it
can be done and I believe in you to do
it more than myself so thank you
everyone congresswoman green wow
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so there was a completely
meaningless meaningless speech there
from Marjorie Taylor green coming up
next is conspiracy theorist Jack
pazoviak with someone named David Marcus
uh yeah so there's gonna be conspiracies
coming up thank you to everyone who's
here and joining me I do want to say
thanks to Peter Switzer who just signed
up on my website also Kathy gavel
Michelle restucci and Jason sickmeyer
just gifted three subscriptions on my
website that puts us at 77 folks there's
a trump rally tonight and if we fill
this bar to a hundred and we're only 23
away
I will do another stream tonight at the
Trump rally here's what's going on there
right now as you can see very exciting
the folks we've talked to here in
Wisconsin are in falling for it they
don't like the fact that the gas prices
still remain substantially higher than
they were under President Trump and the
reality is it's a poor policy for this
nation not right let's see if we have
any new clips here from the Trump rally
uh among some of my
um media sources let's see what we've
got
uh there's stuff from the green speech
already did that
okay I guess probably not right now
we already played that okay no problem
well we're continuing to keep an eye on
it here is uh here's uh pasaviak uh
conspiracy theorist oh thanks to Sam
your dad and Zim sleep Skittle stew has
gifted five putting us at 84.
um let's listen to this
now let me get it let me let me just
let's let's do a little audience poll
David do we want to do you guys want
to hear about all the plans that we have
for the new right
are you ready for a new right are you
ready for new ideas to actually take the
fight to the front lines because that's
where we live and we're not stopping
that's what I'll talk about whoa so
let's from there right because we we
hear about the new right all the time
that this term gets gets bandied about
it's a lot of different factions it's a
lot of different things you know briefly
what does it mean to you that that those
two words so so for me when I hear the
new right I I think the best way I could
encapsulate it is if you think about the
the founding fathers of the new right
and I think for my
in my view the two founding fathers of
the new right are Andrew Breitbart and
Rush Limbaugh oof can we get a round of
applause for Andrew Breitbart and Rush
Limbaugh yikes yikes so but so that's
wait that's that's interesting because I
think that when you look at the new
right and all of the factions they're
really a core four issues that everybody
agrees on right we need a strong border
yes we can't have bad trade deals yes we
need energy Independence yeah and we
have to fight the culture War yes
distinctive looking fellow here
Breitbart and and Rush were there and
the GOP wasn't exactly right the Border
deals with the Democrats they love trade
deals I mean there wasn't if you if you
do not talk about the borders
immigration and trade the Coalition will
fall apart it will completely fall apart
that is the center of it and the outside
piece sort of almost the animating force
is fighting the culture wars against
whether it be woke corporations whether
it be media whether it be the Chamber of
Commerce whether it be everybody that
Kerry Lake had to fight against a couple
nights ago I just got back from Maricopa
County and we all know about Maricopa
County but we put Maricopa County in
their place and we listened to the
people not the bureaucrats
you know isn't isn't isn't part of that
culture War piece that Republicans were
so afraid of being seen as big
government right everything had to be
limited government right and then we saw
what the scientists did this year with
Disney he smacked Mickey Mouse in the
mouth Yes and
[Applause]
unpack that for a second because yeah
it's all packed up but think about that
imagine a state relationship with a
company between Florida and Disney and
the amount of money that Disney has
provided to that state the amount of
Tourism even the outside you know the
secondary tertiary economic effects of
Disney being in Orlando right this is
one of the most powerful companies in
the entire State of Florida so from a
perspective it makes sense that the
governor would not want to go up again
and that's why you saw a series of
governments or Governors who refused to
do this they would work together and
walk the line DeSantis Governor DeSantis
decided to be the one that said you know
what it's too far and these companies
when they step onto the political Arena
when they decide to become politicized
now you're not just part of the the
economy of our area now you're trying to
tell us how we should live how our
children should be raised what we should
teach in our schools and that that is
not the job of corporate America that's
the job of the people and the
representatives of the people and
and I think I
going so far beyond Disney I I guarantee
you two years ago had the Dobbs decision
come down overturning Roe v Wade every
corporation in this country would have
been tweeting about it of course
Hollywood and Major League Baseball
would have been pulling events out of
all the states that none of that
happened this time no the silence was
eerie and the reason that those
corporations were silent was because Ron
DeSantis and all of you quite frankly
have let them know that there is a price
to pay if they interfere in the culture
and the politics of the United States
and that's not going to change
no you're exactly right because they can
sense that the ground is shifted under
their feet and you know Klaus Schwab has
got his great reset oh God we I just
went over there by the way if you guys
know we were over in Davos and uh I was
doing a hit for the War Room do we have
any War Room fans maybe no no no no one
or two oh
I think I see one or two hands in the
back yeah a couple of guys have heard of
it and and we're doing a hit for there
but then we're also doing a documentary
for Turning Point USA and Klaus Schwab
sent his goons out to detain me right
while I was doing a documentary on the
great reset and while I'm standing there
with these World economic Forum assigned
police uh nine millimeters guns drawn
and I'm sitting in the back of my head I
said we are such a threat to you we are
such a threat to this agenda because
they have the great reset we of the
Great Awakening so let me
and and this is what you're saying
because the web wef this is Corporate
power yes but let's so so let me let you
know I I kind of describe the four
things that I think we all have in
common on the new right I do think
there's one area and by the way all four
of those were core Trump issues yes
Trump was less clear in terms of foreign
policy right Trump's foreign policy was
very transactional you never knew what
he was going to do there wasn't exactly
a Doctrine so when it comes to Ukraine
and it comes to those issues you and I
have been sort of on different sides of
this and whereas on those four issues
the new right arrived and voters were
already there it's interesting that
there's not even a single sort of like
um
interesting nuanced thinker in this
entire thing this guy on the right hold
on what was this guy's name Oh Marcus
David something Marcus this is like the
closest that they have and even he's
barely making any sense but other than
this guy sitting on the right it's just
overt delusion at this entire thing
there's nothing even remotely
interesting in any way Odessa we were in
La Vie we were in mikalayev and I've
seen it on the ground and my question
was if we're sending over 60 billion
dollars of U.S money where is it where's
the 60 billion dollars Joe what have you
done with this what percentage and and
when you look you couldn't find the cash
on his trip that laptop and I think that
the American people want to support the
people of Ukraine but they they
inherently know that there's something
going on in between us supporting them
and the money not going to where it
needs to be and that is where you get
politicians connected families oligarchs
but more broadly how do we what is the
what is the American foreign policy that
on the one hand he keeps us out of
expensive entanglements but on the other
hand doesn't just hand geopolitical foes
like Russia and China and Iran win after
win after win so how do we balance that
so this is something that I've actually
talked about and I say this as a Navy
officer that it's it's deterrence right
because if you have strategic deterrence
and credible deterrence we just took out
sawahiri maybe right you know there's
there's some questions about you know
was he taken out before Etc but the idea
is there was it really Trump who took
him out in the military we can Reach Out
And Touch Somebody right without having
to go on board with occupying countries
and nation building and spending
trillions of dollars in the Middle East
instead of rebuilding Detroit and
Chicago and getting our cities under
control doing something about crime here
that we can be effective on the world so
I mean but what is that what is that by
the way does that look like Trump does
that look like Trump saying to Putin if
you invade Ukraine I'm going to there
were reports that he said Moscow says
about the uh right like he himself says
that he put quite a threat out there but
that's his personality how do we there's
no evidence of that whatsoever
to a foreign policy like that was
completely made up right there you look
at Taiwan right now Taiwan is currently
encircled by the Chinese pla by their
the Chinese Navy they're firing missiles
over the island and you look at our U.S
Navy and I'm sorry to say this but as a
prior seven Fleet sailor we need to fix
our Navy right because we're getting
trained in wokeness not training in how
what the military is for is to hurt
people and Break Stuff
I do agree with me that so if if you
re-establish that credible deterrence I
think that solves a lot of yes so back
to the broad question of the new right
are we are we or aren't we at the point
where we can stop calling this the new
right and just call it the right because
you know I've actually been saying that
a little bit right I've been saying that
a little bit and I I don't want to I
don't want to do away with conservatism
and I say this as someone who's you know
I'm a dad I'm god-centered my family's
god-centered we have so many great
Publications out there uh we're doing
human events we're doing all all the new
stuff but we need to understand that
this is like it's almost comical how
absurd and delusional these people are
it's still the new right it's not you
know your granddads you know we're going
to go along to get along we're going to
do the paid how broad can it be I mean
it's obviously it's not going to include
Liz Cheney but doesn't it have to
include a Malia Takis or a catco or or
Northeast Republicans who who I'm
transactional okay transactional you
need you need the person for the
district but at the same same time
you've got to be on board with our
agenda you don't get to dictate our
agenda I think that makes sense and I
think I think we came in right on time I
think we did look at that should we end
on time folks what do you think ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the new right
thank you very much have a great day God
bless completely did I mean it's there
were a lot of words said but absolutely
nothing of any real substance there just
the continued delusions that uh it it is
wild folks let's see if we're gonna have
another stream tonight because we're
getting to the end of this stream I want
to say thank you to Blake Rangel Nicole
Brewer Jason Ford and Eric Arnold who
just signed up on my website putting us
at 89 thanks to Brian Potts Kevin Combs
and Jason sickmeyer who each gifted a
subscription on my website that puts us
at 92. we are very close to 100
and that will lock in a second stream
tonight that stream would be coming to
us from Waukesha Wisconsin as you can
see an electric atmosphere there
awaiting a Donald Trump rally uh
capturing on this fentanyl could kill
the fentanol and right on cue Alexander
Hamilton puts us over the limit with a
10 gifted sub tranche
102 out of the goal of 100 folks we have
locked in another stream for tonight I
plan to be back with you guys somewhere
between 30 and a thousand minutes before
Trump speaks depending on how late he is
ladies and gentlemen we got him we got
him
um oh and thanks to Terry schwarin Terry
also dumping in a another gifted
membership putting us at
103. all right everybody that does it
for me in stream number one tonight's
stream is going to be longer it's going
to be wider it's going to be
girthier for lack of a better term I
will see everybody then this is most of
the interesting stuff from day two of
CPAC so we've got the next stream coming
up tonight and then tomorrow we will be
here for Kimberly guilfile following uh
following followed up by Donald Trump
closing out CPAC that'll be tomorrow but
I will see everybody tonight tonight I
expect a highly triggered Donald Trump I
will see you then
foreign